la CPI la cour internationale a
donc émis un mandat d'arrêt contre
Vladimir Poutine pour sa responsabilité
dans les crimes de guerre perpétré en
Ukraine et notamment dans le crime de
guerre de déportation illégale d'enfants
Ukrainiens Moscou a réagi immédiatement
dénonce une décision je cite
insignifiante et dénuée de sens le chef
de la diplomatie européen Joseph Borel
affirme qu'il s'agit d'une décision
importante Stéphanie Maupas à La Haye
un premier mandat d'arrêt de la Cour sur
l'Ukraine aurait une enquête qui a
débuté rien maintenant plus d'un an et
puis évidemment c'est la première fois
le procureur de la CPI vise la tête de
l'État russe Vladimir Poutine qui est
suspectue donc de déportation d'enfants
ukrainien vers la Russie ce qui
constitue un crime de guerre mais aussi
de transfert illégal toujours dans son
ukrainien mais cette fois vers les
territoires occupés notamment celui dont
mince et puis avec lui si c'était la
commissaire russe au droit de l'enfant
Maria elle va bellova elle est
poursuivie pour pour les mêmes faits
alors il faut savoir que le conte le
contenu exact de ces mandats d'arrêt est
toujours sous scellés mais aussi que ces
mondes portent sur des événements qui
remonte au 24 février depuis le début de
l'invasion russe
et il y a des faits qui ont été dénoncés
du même type de d'enfants de déportation
d'enfants depuis la Crimée qui sont
déroulés avant le début de l'invasion
mais qui ne sont pas visible la prise en
compte par ces mandat d'arrêt Vladimir
Poutine et poursuivi en tant que auteur
directe mais aussi de co-auteur
il a ses pays a expliqué que si elle
n'avait pas rendu public la délivrance
des mandats d'arrêt c'était dans
l'espoir d'avoir un effet dissuasif donc
il faudra voir on sait qu'il y a déjà
une réaction du Kremlin qui explique ne
pas reconnaître la cour que non
internationale
pardon pour les petits problèmes de son
Gauthier wins qui est avec nous bonsoir
Gauthier est-ce que vous pouvez déjà
revenir exactement sur les cette mandat
d'arrêt qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la
responsabilité dans des crimes de guerre
et notamment dans le crime de guerre de
déportation illégale d'enfance ukrainien
alors on touche un point très important
et c'est vrai qu'on en parle pas assez
d'abord ce sont des enfants et quand on
arrache des enfants soit à leurs parents
soit à leur famille quand les parents
sont morts qu'est-ce que c'est si ce
n'est qu'un mépris profond de l'enfant
mais ça ils n'en n'ont qu'une parce que
pour eux ce sont des enfants ukrainiens
et il y a une deuxième chose et qui
concerne non seulement Poutine mais
aussi mariale voie qu'il a cette
commissaire à l'enfance qui a grimpé
dans les dans la carrière russe de
l'animateur à une vitesse un vrai
semblable c'est qu'au fond ce qu'on fait
de ses enfants c'est une sorte
d'acculturation on leur dit vous allez
apprendre l'histoire russe plus on ne
parle plus ukrainien vous allez vous
comporter comme des petits russes et au
fond qu'est-ce que c'est que les débuts
parce que il y a 6000 à peu près enfin
on pense qu'il y en a beaucoup plus mais
c'est les débuts de ce qu'on appelle un
ethnocide ça consiste à enlever à
arracher la culture des personnes
qu'elle soit adulte ou pas et à leur
dire vous ne penserez plus comme ça vous
ne parlerez plus cette langue etc là
c'est encore pire ce sont des enfants et
il y a quelque chose là aussi qui nous
interpelle dans j'allais dire les
réactions les plus élémentaires de ce
qu'est l'être humain faire ça à un
enfant c'est un oui c'est un crime
évidemment et ça va bien au-delà du
crime de guerre probablement c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est de l'ordre
oui de la de la barbarie au même titre
que ce à quoi on assiste à is you sur
les sur les viols sur les les meurtres
et cetera faire ça à un enfant c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas admissible
et là on voit bien l'idée c'est de dire
on va essayer de prendre un maximum
d'enfants
Ukrainiens pour que si nous gagnions
disent les Russes il n'y ait pas un jour
cette relève cette relève de donc de de
classe on peut dire parfois d'élite de
de petits Ukrainiens qui deviendraient
des leaders de l'Ukraine parce que ils
seront à culture ou des culturer alors
Joseph Borel je le disais dit que c'est
une décision importante Moscou dénonce
une décision insignifiante qu'est-ce
qu'elle implique elle implique si vous
voulez qu'à partir du moment où un des
personnages qui est sur lequel pèse un
mandat d'arrêt s'il se déplace s'il est
amené à se déplacer à tel endroit où
justement on se trouve dans un état qui
est signataire de la Cour pénale
internationale sa date de 1998 c'est un
traité de Rome évidemment la Russie ne
l'a pas signé les États-Unis aussi s'en
sont dispensés donc ça veut dire vous
voyez que là où il peut y avoir aussi
des crimes importants on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas juger les gens mais à partir
du moment où la personne se déplace et
ça a été le cas on a même on a même vu
que en ce qui concerne lex Yougoslavie
milosvic a pu être jugé parce que c'est
le pouvoir s'est retourné contre lui le
Rwanda aussi un certain nombre de
hauteurs et de commanditaires du
génocide donc ça c'est important aussi
pour l'opinion publique c'est de dire
attention quelle que soit la puissance
d'un chef d'état d'un potentat d'un
dictateur peu importe il y aura toujours
un moment où il risquera d'être arrêté
et jugé dernière chose contrairement à
ce qu'un dictateur impose assez victimes
c'est-à-dire les tuer ou alors justement
leur arracher leurs racines
si Poutine est un jour condamné ce qui
risquera c'est d'avoir une très belle
cellule à se réveiller à côté de les
Pays-Bas non ça veut dire qu'il faudra
créer un tribunal spécifique pour la
Russie et il ne risque pas la mort lui
et pourquoi parce que nous ne pratiquons
plus et heureusement en Occident ou dans
les pays qui sont signataires la peine
de mort merci Gauthier